[Music]
look who just sent me a text
Eddie McAllister douche she's right
there
that's Alex and like every freshman in
high school his whole life revolves
around his phone right emoji okay be
cool welcome to the world inside your
phone that's my home text topics here
each of us does one thing and we have to
nail it every time Christmas tree just
has to stand there
well festive it's still September Tim
they've just got to wear their crowns
and keep their hair cut
devil poop thumbs up they just show up
and they're good to go but for the faces
the pressure is on me Cryer always has
to cry even if he's just won the lottery
laughing even if he's just broken his
arm now me my name is gene I'm a male so
I got to be totally over it all the time
you know like meh who cares which is not
as easy as it sounds I gotta be
I gotta be mad
[Music]
Poornima ste oh they're so cute it's
hard to always act as a when living in
text offices just so excited hello good
simians those are some sharp at sashays
yes well we have business to attend to
what kind of business monkey business
[Music]
Hey konnichiwa hurry emoticons keep
knocking over the elderly here let me
help let me know Oh Mike :
[Music]
what should I do
each Oh what sending an emoji okay be
cool
welcome to the secret world inside your
phone
we're emojis like me work and live here
each of us does one thing and we have to
nail it every time incoming tax we are
go for men rap hoot me what is that I've
got to get this phone fix this has never
happened before and now alex has made an
appointment to wipe out his phone I'm
not gonna run away from this I made a
mistake but I'm gonna fix it I think we
can make things right
we just have to go to a place where no
emoji has gone before the crowd I know a
shortcut through SMAP but no one's ever
left our city
I'm no softer office
[Music]
what is this place the greatest place
ever
I've never eaten another piece of candy
again high five don't do it
don't you do it it's already been in
there once we need to get the master
password access denied this might take a
while wait what access tonight we're
gonna have some dance our way out
everybody could dance
[Music]